[Music]
thank you so much for being here thank
you for including me so excited to dig
into that career and your thoughts on
the valley and I'm gonna start us off
with one of the things that jumped out
at me in my prep for this interview okay
you are an extremely generous tipper
yeah I love that and I would like to
know why I mean it's pretty I worked so
I mean it's well known and part of why
I'm so open about this is that I think
it gives permission for other people
just to be honest I grew up in a very
kind of dysfunctional household on
welfare and that compounded a bunch of
[ __ ] in my life that was not great we
were very focused on money
it was a huge point of pressure and
tension in the family it created massive
depression in my father drinking just it
was very dysfunctional and there was
some point along the way where I was
like okay is money like really important
or not important and I feel very lucky
because I don't think if you ask my
sisters they got to the same place that
I did but I ended up not coveting it and
I found it to be something that I could
use to really empower myself to do the
things that I wanted to do and so in a
situation where you know you go to a
like a restaurant if you really
empathize with the people that are
working there I see people who are like
me brown skinned working hard creating
these beautiful experiences and then I
can celebrate it by you know I guess
giving a yelp review but you can't buy
food for your kids with a [ __ ] yelp
review so I want a tip and it's it's so
I mean on it gives me so much joy
because it's like you know you'll have
like a three or four hundred dollar bill
in some cases you know you tip five
hundred bucks or a thousand bucks and
you
and they're expecting $40 and I mean
then I'll get a little motion about like
they will come out to you and there it's
transformational and so it's such a
great it's so great it's just like
little things like that mean a lot to
people and just to be anonymously
generous like that I think is like it's
a great gift that I have the ability to
do that's why I do it I love it and it
sounds like the experience of being seen
and get you are seen and the individual
is seen and you're sharing and well I
mean you know it's funny it's like 99%
of the time they don't say anything
because they they do the build thing
afterwards and they for sure can't
pronounce my name
and so they for sure have no [ __ ]
clue who it was I gave them that it's
fine it's totally fine but I love it
I absolutely love it my friends freak
out now it's cause tension of she
because now when I go out with my
friends they know as well and I've just
made it very easy which is like hey if
we're going out just like let me just
[ __ ] pay just like it's just not it's
it's not it's fine
and it makes it simpler yeah I want to
dig into what you were describing about
your upbringing and this unique position
that you've gotten to where you don't
feel that you covet money but you see
its power and they use that it has in
furthering some opportunities for you
how did you develop that how do how do
you distinguish between luck and skill
how do you how do you end up in that
position so I my parents craved money
meaning they needed it because it was it
my dad was unemployed for long stretches
of time my mom was a sole breadwinner
she was a housekeeper then she was in
nurses aide and so and you and I would
just see how she grinded we didn't have
a car for a long time she takes the bus
we all take the bus at you know when
I've got my first job as a Burger King I
take the money and I'd had to give it to
my parents and we would buy bus passes
and you know I remember telling like
some of my friends I went to a very good
high school like kind of like the rich
high school not the high school I should
have gone to I got I was able to go to
this different high school
and I would remember tell I would tell
them like hey this is like yeah I you
know I they I would be so ashamed that I
worked at Burger King they would
sometimes come by and I would just be
like oh [ __ ] like and then at some point
it was just it was like this release
moment where I was like this is my life
like I just I can't do anything about it
this is what it is right now and I kind
of had a sense that I could figure some
stuff out later but I didn't really know
and so I just accepted it and then the
minute I accepted it I wasn't ashamed
anymore and then when I wasn't ashamed I
could start to actually be inside my
head like what really matters so then
what happened was there was these
massive racial riots in Los Angeles and
not as if the [ __ ] American
government did anything about it but the
Canadian government was like [ __ ] let's
get all these black and brown kids jobs
because we don't want the Rodney King
riots in Toronto and Ottawa and parts of
Ontario and so I was able to take all of
my dad's rejection letters call every
single one and one of them gave me a job
and I worked at this well-known
telecommunications start-up in Ottawa
Ottawa had a really burgeoning tech
scene at the time and I worked in this
organization that was run by this really
iconic guy Terry Matthews and he was a
billionaire and I was like what the [ __ ]
is that worth like I mean I didn't even
know [ __ ] thousandaire like I was
like what is a billionaire and this guy
was risk-on and he was just so dynamic
in the businesses he had started and how
he viewed his place in the world and I
was enthralled I was nine degrees away
from him but the cult of personality
around him in that business the lore
when it trickles down to you was not
about you know his conspicuous
consumption or anything else it was
about okay we're launching this frame
relay switch now we're gonna buy this
company okay we're gonna pivot the
entire business to ATM and you were just
like it was an amazing time and so I
took the bus to Newbridge complete luck
that the controller of Newbridge
would go from his nice neighborhood
through this shitty neighborhood to get
on the highway and so he would see this
guy standing by the bus and eventually
he saw me inside the office and one day
he stopped he said your honor right you
work in Newbridge I'm like yeah this guy
Sam leg so in the car he was just he was
in the front seat like beside Terry and
he was able to tell me like how this guy
thought about this I was like because I
would read it in the paper and I'd be
like why is he doing this and like and
he so it just completely rewired what
money was for Terry Matthews money was
an instrument of change right he had a
market cap he's like wow that's eight
billion dollars of change ten billion
dollars have changed fifteen billion
dollars of change versus there was
another guy building a company at the
time his name is Michael Copeland who
ran a company called Carell also a
billionaire and he was the exact
opposite had a messy divorce married
some trophy wife he took this obscene
shiny glass from his building and
covered his house in it and so you had
this this really dislike ah to me of two
different characters at that time in the
90s building really interesting
businesses Corel which was a reasonable
business Newbridge which was a
reasonable business they were both very
successful but they manifested money so
totally differently and I was like I
want to be this guy you know I want to
be this mega compounder swashbuckling
around trying to do really cool [ __ ] in
the world how do I do that and Sam
helped me because it was just like you
you could understand from him what Terry
cared about and then for me I just
copied I mean a lot of my life quite
honest he's just copying things that I
see there's not a lot of original
thought here it truly is not I mean we
can all pretend we're all [ __ ]
geniuses honestly be good copiers do you
know what I'm saying
it's the best thing in the world like be
around high functioning high quality
people and just copy the [ __ ] that they
do observe the [ __ ] that's you know kind
of crappy and then don't do that stuff
it's not [ __ ] complicated formula
when did you use that best no all the
time
I mean look now it's funny like it's
it's like you know like you have a
surface area of ways to spend your time
now or I do and you know I'm in this
midst now where we are really scaling up
what we're doing as a business and I
meet these people that to me are so
iconic that they were sort of like arm's
length people that are now sitting
face-to-face and they treat me like a
quasi periodic quasi pure but what I see
is I see some amazing stuff and I see
some utter dysfunction in some of the
richest most important people in the
world and I have to decide how am I
going to act what am I going to embody
what am i copying what am i not copying
and so I get a chance to now refine my
decision-making and discipline and it's
so that that's how I that's how it plays
out I don't know if I answered questions
I I'm I'm thinking very there's a deep
connection between money as an
instrument of change and what you're
doing now so here's the thing there's
about a hundred and fifty people that
run the world anybody who wants to go
into politics
they're all [ __ ] puppets okay
there are a hundred and fifty in there
all of men that run the world period
full stop they controlled most of the
important assets they control the money
flows and these are not the tech
entrepreneurs now they they are going to
get rolled over over the next five to
ten years by the people that are really
underneath pulling the strings and when
you get behind the curtain and see how
that world works what you realize is it
is unfairly set up for them and their
progeny now I'm not going to say that
that's something that we can rip apart
but first order of business is I want to
break through and be at that table
that's the first order of business and
the way that I do that is by proving
that I can do what they do as well as
they do it and then do it better than
how they do it because at the end of the
day they are commercial [ __ ] animals
okay and they'll open the door out of
curiosity and they'll let me stay
because I because I add value and then
once I'm there I can open the door for
other people who can try to do the same
thing so my entire goal now is that is
to be in a position to aggregate enough
of the capital of the world
- then reallocate it against my world
view and I'm not saying my world view is
the best or right but it is mine and at
the end of the day there are a hundred
and fifty other [ __ ] guys with their
world view and they don't give a [ __ ]
what you think about their [ __ ] world
view that's the truth and so why not me
why not why not one of you why not and
so in my life now I'm just kind of like
why not why the [ __ ] not
what can you tell us a little so you
have these 50-year goals for social
capital yeah three of them yeah can you
give us your world view in through those
goals so my 2045 ambition for the
organization this is as I see it right
now 2045 is I would like us to employ at
least 10 million people through the
businesses that we own I would like our
businesses to positively affect at least
a quarter of the world's population and
I would like us to have made cumulative
Li about a trillion dollars that's my
2045 ambition I think if we do that we
are the modern face of capitalism for
the next 50 years so how we do that now
becomes really important so if you think
about building businesses and today that
could do any of those three things you
have to be technological you absolutely
just have to be you are not going to
build a brick and mortar business that
gets anywhere close to those three
things number one number two is you have
to think very broadly about building
things that can stand the test of time
those businesses are by definition hard
and non-obvious and so they compound in
scale very slowly and that's really
counterintuitive to the overriding logic
of Silicon Valley which says quick fast
go right but that kind of premature
ejaculation doesn't work if you're
trying to [ __ ] be around forever like
you've got to be in the flow for decades
that is hard it tests people's patience
it tests people's resolve it tests
people's really intellectual incision
and this is where everybody gives up
everybody gives up I had this moment
today just a total different way of
describing this through the warriors
I've met a lot of players obviously one
of them who I become unbelievably close
to as David Lee David Lee just got
engaged to this unbelievable woman
Caroline Wozniacki
tennis player anyways we were working
out this morning okay
couples workout me and my wife him and
him and his fiance so we're doing this
thing this treadmill thing which my
trainer would concocted and I mean I
mean I'm in pretty good shape and then
you see what it really means to be
extremely dedicated in their case to
something which is physical fitness
because they're professional athletes
when I give up but when the average
human gives up their brain goes into
[ __ ] overdrive okay and they're like
there's this next level burst and so
like it's it's that it's like when when
things get hard can you double down a
different example we had yesterday we do
these things every quarter called
quarterly portfolio reviews we're
incredibly intensive review of our
entire portfolio revisiting our strategy
talking about all the things we're doing
to make sure we're on the right track
and I had this observation which was I
started a diabetes business my dad died
of diabetes three years ago most of my
relatives have it I expressed the gene
that makes me disproportionately
susceptible to it so it's something that
I personally care about but that
business took seven years to get to a
place where we even have a chance of
being viable and I think to myself in
that example I embodied a bit of
Caroline Wozniacki when things got hard
I pushed through the pain now in my case
the pain was the fear of failure
continuing to write more money a belief
that I had that this business was going
to work and today that business manages
a million diabetics and I think there is
some kid out there whose family will be
slightly less dysfunctional because
their parents disease is better managed
it's not going to go to a place where
like you know they're getting dialyzed
or you know they're on an organ registry
and that value for that kid in our world
and all of you that benefits will never
be connected the dots but that's okay
but it required just resilience and I'm
proud of that yeah and so I want to
bring back a little bit of that here so
that it's not quick fast five million
users ten million
flip it sell it great celebrate it's
like hey let's work on some hard [ __ ]
together let's like buckle down and look
each other in the eye and say we're
gonna support each other here this gonna
take seven or eight years but if it
works it will really mean something and
it's something that matters to you for
something that's other than just simple
motivation of the social capital you get
from your friends or money in the short
term and winning bigger longer-term
we're missing that and I think like part
of our success will be if we can stay
focus on that our education portfolio is
another thing it literally looked like a
train wreck for three years where
everybody has always said you never
invest in education and my thing was
it's not about education this is about
human capital development it's about for
every one of you who's so smart that got
into Stanford think of all the people
who could be as capable I'm not asking
you to empathize with them but I as a
capitalist want a starting line where
all of those people can run a race so
that I can pick the winner no offense to
any of you here and it took us three
years we're now those building blocks
exists and I'm like wow how many times
did have to look at my partner's is they
know the easy answer is to walk away the
hard answer is to double down we have to
support this business that culture is
missing here so part of what we're
trying to do to achieve those goals is
like take really big audacious points of
view on the world and then train
ourselves to be patient and it's really
really hard the entire society is set up
to not be patient anymore and I'm
hearing also a conflict with this like
fail fast and learn mentality where if
if you're taking a deep and big bet like
you want it to be the right one how do
you know when that's true I think that
that's fail-fast approach works in
consumer internet businesses but I don't
think it works for anything that really
matters
basically consumer internet businesses
are about exploiting psychology and that
is one where you want to feel fast
because you know people aren't
predictable and so we want to
psychologically figure out how to
manipulate you as fast as possible and
then give you back that dopamine hit we
did that brilliantly at Facebook
Instagram has done it whatsapp has done
it
you know snapchat has done it Twitter
has done it so there are great examples
we chat has doing it there are great
examples of failing fast is the right
path to exploiting psychology of mass
populations of people but it is not how
you solve diabetes it is not how you use
precision medicine to cure cancer it is
not how you educate broad swaths of the
world's population it's just not it's
taking a point of view and being
methodical nothing heart no it's hard
I'm glad that you're taking a stab at it
by the way if it works it's where all
the money comes like if you talk about
where all of the gains where all of the
value will be created over the next 50
years it'll be in those heart things and
the reason is because those white spaces
are so wide open the competitive
pressures are non-existent for example
today you have this weirdly academic
argument about climate change it exists
it doesn't exist while we were in an ice
age now it's one of course you're who
care who cares what's undeniable is that
we're ripping apart the biodiversity of
our planet what is undeniable is that we
as a human population will be forced to
concentrate because certain parts of the
world will get basically you know
subsume by water we do not have food
supplies that these are conclusively
known to be true yet nobody's really
working on a problem and part of it is
because the people won't have the
ambition to try to go after it the
capital markets don't reward that kind
of decision-making but if somebody were
to solve it don't you think that they
are in economic terms a multi
trillionaire of course you think food
delivery is where like the next great
[ __ ] breakthrough is gonna come
you're all hopped up on [ __ ]
marijuana and you need a [ __ ] brownie
like what a joke okay go ahead go and
look through crunchbase not that shitty
useless idiotic companies that have
gotten funded doing garbage like that
versus climate change think about that
think about that think about that when
you guys eventually find your partner
your significant other your husband your
wife you get married you have kids you
will not be able to hand off a planet
that they can predictably live in you
will not your generation and nobody is
[ __ ] doing anything about it so the
capital markets work just completely
completely out of their minds and so I
[Applause]
want to bring us back to the point that
you were making about exploiting
consumer behavior in a consumer internet
business you said that this is a time
for soul-searching in social media
businesses and and you were part of
building the largest one what
soul-searching are you doing right now
on that I feel tremendous guilt I think
we I think we all knew in the back of
our minds even though we feigned this
whole line of like there probably aren't
any really bad unintended consequences I
think in the back deep deep recesses of
our minds we we kind of knew something
bad could happen but I think the way we
defined it was not like this it
literally is a point now where I think
we have created tools that are ripping
apart the social fabric of how society
works that is truly where we are and I
would encourage all of you as the future
leaders of the world to really
internalize how important this is if you
feed the Beast that beast will destroy
you if you push back on it we have a
chance to control it and rein it in and
it is a point in time where people need
to hard break from some of these tools
and the things that you rely on
the short-term dopamine driven feedback
loops that we have created are
destroying how society works no civil
discourse no cooperation misinformation
miss truth and it's not an American
problem this is not about Russian ads
this is a global problem so we are in a
really bad state of affairs right now in
my opinion it is it is eroding the core
foundations of how people behave by and
between each other and I don't have a
good solution you know my solution is I
just don't use these tools anymore I
haven't for years it's created huge
tension with my friends
huge tensions in my social circles if
you look at like you know my facebook
for you I probably haven't I posted
maybe two times in seven years three
times five times like just it's less
than 10 and it's weird I guess I kind of
just innately didn't want to get
programmed and so I just tuned it out
but I didn't confront it and now to see
what's happening it's really it really
it really bums me up like think about
like there were these examples where
there was a hoax in whatsapp where in
some like village in India people were
like afraid that their kids were gonna
get kidnapped etc and then there were
these lynchings that happened as a
result where people were like vigilante
running around they think they found the
person and they I mean I mean seriously
like that's what we're dealing with you
know and imagine like when you take that
to the extreme where you know bad actors
can now manipulate large swaths of
people to do anything you want it's just
a it's a really really bad state of
affairs and we compound the problem
right we curate our lives around this
perceived sense of perfection because we
get rewarded in these short-term signals
hearts likes thumbs up and we conflate
that with Valley
and we conflate it with truth and
instead what it really is is fake
brittle popularity
that's short-term and that leaves you
even more and admit it vacant and empty
before you did it because then it forces
you into this vicious cycle where you're
like what's the next thing I need to do
now because I need it back
think about that compounded by two
billion people and then think about how
people react then to the perceptions of
others it's just a it's really bad it's
really really bad
it sounds like you're taking deep
personal responsibility also in and
being a part of it I kind of look I did
it I did what I did a great job there
and I think that business overwhelmingly
does positive good in the world where I
have decided to spend my time is to take
the capital that they rewarded me with
and now focus on the structural changes
that I can control I can't control that
I can control my decisions which is I
don't use a [ __ ] I can control my kids
decisions which is they're not allowed
to use this [ __ ] and then I can go focus
on diabetes and education and climate
change that's what I can do but
everybody else has to soul-search a
little bit more about what you're
willing to do because your behaviors you
don't realize it but you are being
programmed it was unintentional but now
you got to decide how much you're
willing to give up how much of your
intellectual independence and don't
think oh yeah not me I'm [ __ ] genius
I'm at Stanford you're probably the most
likely to [ __ ] fall for it
because you were [ __ ] check boxing
your whole goddamn life no offense guys
none taken
so how I mean you've been outspoken
about the Trump to administration's
position on immigration on on a number I
mean these things are gonna collide in
government and business right that's
happening now yeah so what what do you
want these future business leaders to do
about it once they get into that spot
get the money get the money and then
let's get around a table and let's
create new rules literally that simple
get the [ __ ] money I'm serious do not
get it it is gonna be made it is going
to be allocated and you have a moral
imperative to make sure that if you have
a point of view that matters and you
want to reflect it you get it I'm gonna
go get it other people are gonna go get
it and then it will be about a
competition of views and don't wrap
yourself in all this like you know
liberal kind of [ __ ] about oh my god
money blah no stop here's how the
[ __ ] world works okay it drives the
world for better or for worse economic
incentives Drive entire swaths of
populations to behave in very very
predictable and then when you when you
take it away unpredictable ways ask
anybody in your class that's from a
developing nation ask anybody in your
class like who has seen that play out
from where they're from so that's what
you have to do you gotta go and get it
if you control the capital and you have
a point of view you can now then the
question is don't be a sellout whatever
your worldview is you should be spending
time to think about what that is so that
when you control some of these purse
strings you push that view into the
world I will never judge you and you
should not judge me for what that
worldview is but the point is the more
diversity of those views
the more rational actors we have and the
more of a balanced fare system that is
what diversity really means to me it
doesn't mean like let's manage back to a
quota you know it doesn't mean like okay
we need a black guy a brown guy we need
a few that's not what it means this is
what it means right there are people in
this audience that have probably dealt
with the same kind of like life that
I've dealt with you have a very unique
world view that matters and in the
absence of capital you're irrelevant
with capital you're powerful and then
you decide in small ways and
medium-sized ways and large ways right
and it just depends on the scale of
capital that you have and so that's
what's necessary now in capitalism which
is that we have to come back to like
what is it really is it an economic
system yes but it is a philosophy as
well right and it's a philosophy that
says we will vote for the change we
intend based on the views that we have
and when you look at the most successful
people that operate in these tentacles
that's what they do look at the Koch
brothers that's what they do they have
built a network of influence based on
capital their world view is propagated
into the world at an unbelievably
aggressive rate that has been
compounding for decades that is genius
it is genius it doesn't matter whether
you agree with their worldview the
question is what's the counterweight to
their worldview can you name what can
you name a group of people that operate
in the exact same way methodically
meticulously assembling Capital
influence assets who believe the
opposite irrespective of what you think
of the koch's you want both views out in
the world at scale well right now you
have this and you don't have this and
there are many examples of that and so
get the money and don't lose your moral
compass when you do you said that you
think VC is a horrendous allocator of
capital so if we need to go get the
capital how do we do it better
well we're chipping away I think other
people will copy us you know venture is
basically just a bunch of soulless
cowards you know like they're all
they're all just kind of look they're
well-intentioned but they're
well-intentioned soulless cowards they
have fallen for what everybody else
falls for which is not which is which
you can't blame them for which is here
is this gold star and they're like wow
I've gotten a gold star and then the
minute you do that what you do is you
start to just choke it really tight and
you're like I don't want to lose this
gold star and then what happens you go
risk-off and then what happens your
behaviors are about protecting the seed
of power that you have the social
definition that that seat affords you
and so now instead of being an
accelerant of a progressive worldview
you become a retardant to a progressive
worldview right your risk appetite
shrinks the surface area in which you're
willing to make decisions shrink you so
you you eat and when you are a critical
part of the future again going back to
how I started the most important part of
capitalism is going to be the folks that
are driving the technological change
well as a class that's what VCS are
supposed to do but they're by and large
in my opinion the wrong people so how do
we do it you have to make it more
systematic you have to make it more
data-driven you have to strip out the
bias you have to be open 24/7 you know
you can't have these dumb rules of like
oh I only do deals if they're like
within 15 you know miles driving
distance like how can the most important
part of it
I mean did you can you imagine if I
walked in to Zach's office Facebook
board I'm like I have a great [ __ ]
idea
Facebook is only going to be open for
business Monday through Friday 10:00 to
5:00 kids want to get home
summers we're gonna take off and so the
pitch is going to show like a 404 page
and if you make sense like over like
Google you know you we only want you to
search during business hours and so you
know you have so you have to be open for
scale you have to be global you have to
do all of these things so that you can
get the money into the hands of the
people that deserve it and then help
them and by helping them what you have
to do is actually address the core
structural parts of business building
that are not done well today and the
best analog is AWS if you were starting
a business 15 years ago I can even tell
you a decade ago we were racking servers
in our data center because the growth
was great and somewhere along the way
Amazon said you know what all of that
complexity is necessary but it's not
sufficient to building Facebook or any
other great company so let me abstract
that for you let me go and replace all
of those good people with an API and
I'll take those good people and they'll
be celebrated at Amazon and initially a
few people said yes and you know people
thought in 2007 AWS was a joke and we
used to laugh at it we're like why would
anybody do this stuff and now see how
fast the decade later you're on the
other side of the fence if any come any
of you guys start a business and you're
not on AWS you would be at the joke
right so what did they do they basically
said here's all this stuff that's
necessary to building a business you
need to do it you probably don't want to
do it you're probably not going to do it
well and so let me just replace it all
with an abstraction your company can be
smaller leaner more efficient and now
the money you raise can be used for
things that approximate core product
value better okay now in 2017 asked the
same question
what's the next set of things that make
sense and in my opinion what we
uncovered at Facebook is what every
company needs which is how do you shift
from an anecdotal political capital
social capital oriented way of making
decisions aside a company to a very
precise unemotional data-driven process
and the way you do it is by building a
bunch of data infrastructure by
collecting a bunch of data itself by
helping you optimize your business in a
bunch of obvious and non-obvious ways
and so what we believe is that we should
take that capability that that my team
built at Facebook and abstracted for all
of you who intend to start a company so
now in the future what should happen is
you'll go to AWS you'll get some
infrastructure you'll go to social
capital comm and you'll get some
insights and knowledge and it's all
interacting via api's it's all in
interaction via endpoints and primitives
and what happens is we can now learn
from the feedback from your data how
you're doing we can merge those
learnings across many many other
businesses we can find things in some
remote part of some company over here
and translate that as value for you over
here wouldn't you want that
of course you'd want that you know what
if we could do more efficient customer
acquisition what if we could figure out
churn better what if we so all of these
things now are what we are going to
bring to the market systemic
capabilities and I think over time what
that does is again it moves to a much
more progressive view of what capitalism
should be it's not the few that matched
a human driven pattern but it's more
about taking big shots scaling up the
money being able to support people in
structurally predictable ways and
allowing them to build better companies
those companies I suspect will be as
profitable but they'll be smaller
they'll be more efficient they'll have
more revenue per head all the things
that you would want over time so that
instead of having four or five mega
companies you could have millions and
millions and millions of smaller better
run companies and that's my worldview
and I think if we do that we achieve our
goals
we kind of focus on hard product all of
that stuff comes together if we enable
that so what you're seeing from us is
that
it's really upsetting and disconcerting
to the established sort of venture
classes because it up ends how they've
defined their value it's a very classic
inventors dilemma right they are like in
my brain is pattern recognition but we
know that that's not true and the data
shows you that that's not true
you know simple question for all of you
guys that love the lore of Silicon
Valley from the 70s when Microsoft was
founded - now if you look at all the
major companies that have been created
major say over 50 billion over 60
billion what percentage of the series a
investors overlapped you did the a of
Microsoft and you did the a of Google or
you did the a of uber right like we're
pattern recognition again you know it's
non-numerical right it's about like wow
I like the cut of this guy's Jim you
know well the answer is it's it's less
than 2% so what does that mean
everybody's bullshitting that's what it
really means right
if you're in a seat and you have good
deal flow and you have precious capital
and there's a massive tailwind
of technological change over time you
get one of the twenty hang you look like
a genius that's basically what's
happening and nobody wants to admit that
but that's the [ __ ] truth it's the
truth
so if anybody looks at you and tells you
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing
they're lying they're lying they are
lying to themselves at a minimum and at
a maximum they're lying to you because
the data does not support that claim and
that's irrefutable so I don't want to be
one of those people that stumble into a
company and look back and like oh yeah
we were geniuses I want us to be
systematic and I want us to be able to
deploy tools and capabilities that get
us closer and closer to that and that is
what if you're again a traditionalist
freaks you out and that's what allows
you to make these much longer-term
commitments to businesses that are going
to address healthcare education
no I've got that's just because I'm rich
but no I mean is it to be honest like I
I don't need anybody else's money that's
like look this is not like a popular
view so the first [ __ ] billion
dollars is mine and then I have to prove
it and then other people glom on but I
mean many of them started by caring but
I suspect over time if we end up with a
hundred two hundred five hundred billion
dollars
how much of that last 5060 percent
really care that's okay I want the
[ __ ] money I will play the goddamn
game you know win because I want the
money because I want to extend my
influence do you know what I'm saying
yeah they want to return it's fine
he wants the money because I want to win
I I so deeply want to win how I'm just
gonna say this exactly as it's coming
how do you keep that power from
corrupting you I have no idea that's the
honest answer I have no idea I've become
increasingly isolated it's harder and
harder for me to connect because I'm so
in my own mind like how does this all
play out you know how do i how do i
fundraise how do I make how do I help
facilitate good investing decisions
which really means how do I help this
great team think about a more platform
eyes approach and in that I just get
really isolated and so I don't have a
good answer I like things like this and
I I like to say the things that I do and
maybe it helps you in your own lives but
to be honest it's very selfish it helps
me because like it reminds me of when
I'm in a place like it reminds me of
these stories like just reminding myself
like I made 455 an hour Burger King I
would get a $50 check and I'd buy bus
passes that's awesome I just I don't
ever want to forget that
and I'll go months and not remember that
but now as I say it I'm like okay I'm I
was I started a good earnest person and
I need to stay a good earnest person so
I don't have a good answer and I'll tell
you of those 150 people maybe it's a
little bit more but I've met a lot of
them it's it's it's really hard you it's
very easy to end up really drunk with
power it's really hard yeah I really
appreciate that candor because I don't
think that we get it very often and
you've laid out an incredible vision for
money as an instrument of change so I'm
really grateful that you were here to
share it with us today thank you and
we're gonna open it up now to questions
I'm sure that there are many follow-ups
on what you've explored but any feedback
[Applause]
hi I'm Dana I'm second year MBA at GSP
thank you for being with us today but
I'm not here to give feedback but I have
a question for you you just took social
capital Quito Sophia topic
I wonder what's your plan to run this
public fund how would that be different
from running a private fund or it's just
another way to get money
so awesome yes but no uh so one of the
things that I think about a lot is if I
am in a position to reshape I've been in
a position where I was a part of a group
that helped shape psychology of society
that's been a great experience and and
and I learned a lot and so now in this
position what I say to myself is what
are the psychological things I'd love to
change now and one of them is around
this idea of patience and what's
counterintuitive and I said this earlier
when we were just talking is that I
think bringing liquidity into companies
sooner will actually allow companies to
bake longer and more patiently and so
part of what this vehicle is is about
bringing liquidity sooner in a company's
life cycle because if we can take this
company use it to acquire something else
and that CEO is now able to compensate
their employees as counterintuitive as
it sounds I suspect that they are less
likely to leave and so now you could
have employees stay at a business for
seven eight nine ten years which used to
be the historical norm and now it's not
most of you probably are thinking to
yourselves well I'm gonna get a great
job at the JI after the GSB but I should
probably portfolio manage my my career
for the next six or seven years 18
months here 18 months there 18 months
there and then I'll decide what I really
want to do and part of it is because
there's an incentive to sort of like
build this kind of portfolio approach
but I suspect if you knew that liquidity
was sort of like a more traditional
predictable thing many people would
actually say you know what I like these
people here I like the mission of the
company I want to continue to help
advance their goals and now that you've
actually you know solved my compensation
problem I'm willing to commit so part of
this vehicle is trying to turn back the
incentives towards people staying at
companies longer which i think is going
to be required if you're gonna try to
solve hard problems because if right now
the Silicon Valley attrition rates in
most companies twenty percent that means
every five years your entire employee
base is turned over think about that how
do anything valuable if everybody is new
every five years how is that possible
it's probably not possible so that's
what I'm that's what I would try to
change and get the money hi I'm Carolyn
I'm also an MBA - your sports analogy of
kind of buckling down and going into
hyperdrive really resonated with me I
also realized that that can go too far
so I'm curious to hear how you make some
of the tough calls on whether it's not
to participate in the next round of
fundraising or whatever that looks like
to you how do you make those decisions
this is honestly this is that so
yesterday it's we spent an inordinate
amount of time talking about this we've
made a bunch of decisions that I deeply
regret because they were entirely
monetary in nature and what I said to
the team was I'm fine with us making
purely monetary decisions but we didn't
even do those well it's not as if we
like had a predictable rate of return on
that that said yeah you know what we're
just gonna kind of like close our eyes
here you know double our money and walk
away and so the reason I brought that up
to them was I was like our
decision-making can't bleed over time
and right now it's very hard for us as
an organization to know how much it
should be mission driven how much should
not when should we really double down on
things that are not working when should
we not when should we just give up
because it's just either the timing is
not the right time and quite honestly I
don't have a very good answer but if it
is the thing that we are now I would say
the most emotionally sensitive - because
for example the opposite may be true so
if the diabetes business turns out to
work does the hundred and first person
that works at social capital say [ __ ] it
we're just gonna buckle down and you
know when they're writing checks all of
a sudden were 50 million deep into
something that is clearly not going to
work was that it so I don't have a
really good answer but it is the thing
that I think about the most when do you
know how do you know to keep going for
it when do you know that it's just too
much when do you know that your
decision-making is bleeding into a vein
that is not constructive
I have no idea so Billy's a great
question it's it's I think about that a
lot probably a lot of things like it's
really powerful to be able to say I
don't know I mean I would just encourage
you guys all to just be like I don't
know like this culture like American
culture it's this weird thing of like
know-it-alls everybody has to know
everything how the [ __ ] can you ever
learn how is when is that gonna be
valuable
don't be the just own own that that one
line I don't know it's so powerful and
as I kind of like get more abstracted
when I meet people and I ask them things
it is so endearing to hear I don't know
because behind that it's just like just
a self-awareness and confidence that I
think is increasingly rare now you guys
are like I'm gonna [ __ ] grin [ __ ]
this guy and just keep telling everybody
I don't know don't do that I mean really
own it if you're gonna say it really own
it but I really think it's a very
powerful thing to be able to say I don't
know hi my name is Venusian and I'm a
first year MBA student I'm also a
Canadian who went to Waterloo and my
first job was at Burger King so I really
see you as a role model my [ __ ]
brother you look like me - it's crazy to
think are you planket or good actor I
swear I swear to God well you're really
freaking me out right now
what do you want so my question for you
is a couple years ago at an event in HBS
you mentioned that MBA students are
typically at a disadvantage with respect
to getting capital if they pursue
entrepreneurship do you think that still
holds true today if so that's a perfect
example of me before Cass which team
haven't talked about expressing my bias
and I think part of my bias came from my
insecurities about not having a grad
degree part of my bias was like looking
at people like you saying wow I just
feel inferior to folks like you I've had
felt for huge amounts of time and so
it's a perfect example where even though
I can say it my what I said at that HBS
thing was me just spouting off making
myself feel better about my biases and
what I would tell you today is it can
matter it doesn't matter I would rather
say that there are ways of figuring out
how valuable you are that are
independent of those traditional signals
whether you have them or not so I would
say today I've changed my mind that's
another thing changing your mind is so
powerful I mean [ __ ] change your mind it
makes for really really really bursty
difficult marriages at times my wife
will tell you but man is it powerful in
business change your mind all the time
and it's amazing again where you'll find
like really good scaled leaders want the
right answer and they're fine with
capitulation they're fine with change
they really are because they just want
the right answer and then you just get
so invested in an answer and then you
build up all of this superficial logic
to reinforce it versus saying I don't
know
let me oh you know what I changed my
mind Wow another powerful thing I think
I show you my mind all the time I think
this is gonna be our last question I saw
some of the venture world at South Bank
some of the tech world and you said
something about amassing capital today
what do you think
one of the best ways for us to amass
capital on a risk-adjusted basis I mean
the last part is just such a sellout a
risk-adjusted base I don't [ __ ] buy
some bonds I mean I don't know here's
what I would tell you man I think I
think if you ask me who's building the
most important indelible company in the
world I've been very public about this I
think it's Jeff Bezos part of what he
realized was the value of slow
compounding so here's my little theory
about company value creation
the faster you build it that is the
half-life it will get destroyed in the
same amount of time and so when you
think about a lot of like social
businesses that's played out but and
when you see sort of like what the sort
of like the tops are like you know does
it take eight nine ten years to build a
really great consumer business
it'll take 8 9 10 12 years to destroy it
and we may see the tipping point on a
couple of these businesses right now we
may be seeing it in front of our eyes
regulatory otherwise so why is that an
important statement amassing capital to
me is about finding a smart useful
solution to a very hard practical
problem and being slow and methodical
and again this what I'm saying you have
to rewire your brain for that to be okay
how do you in year two or year five come
back to this room for your what is it
called when you get reunion and say I'm
still working on the same thing and when
somebody says and how's it going you
have the courage to say it's hard I
haven't figured it out yet I don't know
but if you figure it out and you have
this moderate growth moderate
compounding that that is the key that is
like that's gold you know I look at like
our returns and it's so funny because
it's like you can get so enthralled by
IR ours in our business and like you
know I have I have friends who run other
organizations and they're like we posted
92% pi RR and I'm like well you can't
eat
what does it really mean and when you
unpack it what you realize is like fast
money returns can completely really
decay long-term thinking and sound
judgment and so I'm like wow I would
really love to just compound at 15% a
year and the reason is because if I can
do that for 50 years that's 250 [ __ ]
billion dollars like some crazy number
like it's just enormous so it's like
slow and steady against heart problems
start by turning off your social apps
and giving your brain a break because
then you will at least be a little bit
more motivated to not be motivated by
what everybody else [ __ ] thinks about
you do you know what I'm saying
it's hard think about how all this stuff
plays together how does trying to get
you know posting your [ __ ] waffles
online relate to me starting a business
and accumulating capital
this is wiring your brain for superfast
feedback it's the same brain you're
using to build a company don't think
they're not the same do you know what
I'm saying no yes give one break so
you're training your brain here whether
you think it or not whether you know it
or not whether you acknowledge your not
acknowledge that these things where
you're spending hours a day are rewiring
your psychology and physiology in a way
that now you have to use to go and
figure out how to be productive in the
commercial world so if you don't change
this you are going to get the same
behaviors over here change this there's
a reason why Steve Jobs was like
antisocial media I am Telling You I'm
not on these [ __ ] apps I'm not him by
any stretch of the imagination but I am
proactively trying to rewire my brain
chemistry to not be short-term focused
I'm telling you they're linked come on
thank you so much for being here and
[Applause]